that look like bags I don't know hey
guys it is 13 on its grades and that
means it's time for me to teach you how
to do something what do I call this day
tipsy Thursday Thirsty Thursday thirst
for knowledge
I don't know Oh guys this is where it
gets real fun I talked to you guys about
this last summer because I became
obsessed with this show and I'm obsessed
with it again this summer it's a show
that exists on YouTube a reality show
called
action or break if you don't know what
the show is it is a reality show that
happens over the course of the summer
with a bunch of 18 - like 20 year olds
high school juniors seniors they all
live in California for the summer and
they just hang out with each other but
the interesting thing about this reality
show is unlike television doesn't like
shoot a season and then air the full
season this is shooting in almost real
time and all of the kids have social
media so they're all on Twitter and
snapchat and vine like real kids they're
all seeing each other's lives on social
media so when they hang out again they
talk about it which also makes me
terrified it's like this is what kids
say and do and communicate this is how
they be with each other ah ah Jesus
they're back for season 2 and the keys
are wonderfully dumb delightfully
underdeveloped socially and
communicatively it's so words I love all
things like bad reality programming and
this is kind of it except the kids are
actually like sweet and nice at the end
of the day like the they seem
good-natured and good-hearted
they just seem remember those toys that
they always used to have in front of toy
stores that were those like electronic
bags of like I'm a mouse and its tail
would flop around as if there's like a
mouse or something caught in the bag
these kids are just those flopping bags
of hormones that are just all trying to
get out of their bags and into each
other's bags it's just like it is
so based on that show I thought today I
would teach you how to communicate like
a teenager when you're going to have a
sincere conversation start with a word
that ends in ly honestly you can tell me
no but seriously like literally honestly
legitimately honestly literally I
Mandarin your speak like I just like
like um like literally like like I just
like touch something and play with
something or fiddle with something
around you to keep you occupied /
thinking about something other than
getting a boner I like honestly like
didn't understand like like honestly
like when add in some more ly words
honestly I'm sitting here like thinking
like to myself literally like
non-judgmentally like start to get your
point out I just I'm trying to be really
carefully we're like legitimately like I
honestly think this is good for us don't
forget it some point in the middle of
the conversation to include some sort of
weird hand gesture that is a sign of
camaraderie so I want to talk to you
about like getting turnt up turnt up
like sometimes you get turnt up sprinkle
me for that one don't forget to throw in
some words that seem like gibberish but
do you really mean something more
towards you know let's get Phipps
neutered derp top pam pam and tam Tam's
like you know always be like dwarf dwarf
sprinkle that and in an unfinished
sentence seriously thank you for like
listening to me and like I really
honestly like yeah
creatine yeah there you go there's how
to conversate like a teenager I hope
this helps you stay conversely stunted
is that a phrase I don't know I've made
it up that's how to talk like a late 20s
or you don't mean to check out I can I
look like on YouTube if you like reality
television and living vicariously
through pseudo relationships I
Michael he links for the show are down
below along with all the links to all
the characters instagrammed characters
the humans this is a real people show if
it was scripted
I'd be like someone gotta fire that
writer also they had a party I've become
and I went to it just keeps up crazy
the youth terrifies me like seriously I
want to hear this like I seriously it
legit I think this will be like like pop
rocks and like pam pam and tam Tam's
like long long boards